rural Maine may inspire artists Tonya
Hollanders work but when she decided to
get an abortion her home state presented
many obstacles its administrative
requirements and lack of available
doctors meant she'd have to wait nearly
a month for the procedure after
discovering she was pregnant putting her
at risk of exceeding the 10 week limit
for medical abortions which are induced
by pill I felt betrayed by my community
honestly by doctors by politicians by
all of the people that protest like you
have they have no idea what it's like to
add all of those burdens on when you're
making a really hard life decision she
ended up making a day-long trip to
another state where her insurance
wouldn't cover the cost of the procedure
but a new law will mean less of a wait
and mean it allows nurse practitioners
like Julie Jenkins to perform some early
in office abortions this is well within
my scope of practice we are well
equipped and have similar efficacy rates
for Docs and advanced practice
clinicians those who oppose abortion on
moral grounds had argued the change
would put women at risk but jenkins says
the procedure is similar to another she
already performs after a miscarriage
since 2011 many states have passed laws
restricting access to abortion setting
up a possible Supreme Court battle that
could alter abortion rights nationwide
here in Maine though they've been moving
in the opposite direction looking to
protect and expand access ever since
Democrats took control of the State
House in 2018 abortion providers say the
law will make it easier for women who'd
have to travel long distances to get the
procedure from a doctor sometimes
somebody can live fairly close to one of
our clinics but there are so many
obstacles and so many challenges for
people things like child care getting
off work
if they're an abusive relationship and
maybe their partner does not know about
the abortion and it's not supportive
gathering the funds all of these things
impact their ability to even make it to
a clinic nearby particularly in a state
like Maine with snowy winters and little
public transportation where not all
women have the means Hollander did to
get the medical care they desire
Kristen salumi aljazeera Auburn Maine